now attentions have been building along
India's disputed border with China a
number of skirmishes between opposing
troops have taken place over the last
month now reports of an increase in
troop numbers on both sides are fueling
fears of a bigger confrontation between
the nuclear-armed neighbors India and
Chinese military commanders are holding
talks today to try to defuse the
situation more on that in a moment but
first this report on how India and China
came to blows in the first place located
high in the Himalayan mountains the
Indian region of Ladakh is known for its
natural beauty but in May it was also
the site of tensions scuffles broke out
between Indian and Chinese troops the
region lies close to one of the most
hotly contested borders in the world
between India and China the yellow line
on this map marks the boundary between
the two countries
it's known as the line of actual control
but it's not a hard frontier as China
and India never agreed on where their
official border should lie in 1962 the
two nations fought a war over the issue
but failed to resolve the problem in the
decades since that conflict there have
been several standoffs between Chinese
and Indian troops patrolling the area
one of the longest and most serious was
in 2017
in the summer of that year the two sides
confronted each other for 73 days after
Indian troops blocked construction of a
road by China the leaders of India and
China discussed the problem at meetings
in 2018 and 2019 they promised to
maintain the peace but they made no
progress on settling the issue of who
owns the land in the border area
nevertheless they put mechanisms in
place to prevent lethal flare-ups
between troops but recent satellite
imagery posted on Twitter by an
Australian security analyst suggests
both sides are building up their
military presence in the area and this
is causing concern that another more
serious confrontation could be looming
DW correspondent Nimisha Joyce wall
joins us now from Delhi Nimisha a good
to have you with us now our people in
the region worried that this conflict
could escalate into something more
dangerous I mean there are definitely
concerns because we are talking about
two massive nuclear-armed nations but in
India especially there is a difference
between what happens when we are in one
fixed with Pakistan versus when India
sees a conflict with China now the kind
of aggressive almost jingoism that we
see and assuring that we see with
Pakistan is largely absent when it comes
to China
analysts believe analysts believe that
this could be because of China's
conventional warfare military
superiority but on the other hand we
also see Indians coming together to try
to clamp down on trade ties with China
for example a removed China AB became
very popular in India in the last two
weeks because of the fact that they were
trying to remove all Chinese apps from
their phones they've also been Indian
celebrities coming out and saying stop
buying Chinese products hit them where
it hurts but of course there's a 90
billion dollar trade between the two
countries and downloading and removing a
few apps is probably not going to have
much of a damaging effect on the Asian
giant India and China seem to be making
an effort to resolve this conflict
military commanders are meeting at a
border post there now what are they
hoping to achieve well that's right I
mean already there have been ten rounds
of military talks at lower levels
leading up to this however this did not
lead to any positive results yesterday
there was some progress because
diplomats from the two countries got on
to a video conference together and spoke
about how a dispute between the two
countries must be resolved through
peaceful discussion these military talks
are a step towards that they are also
saying they do not expect a complete
resolution right now but it seems that
India has already stocks and India is
requesting for China to allow for
infrastructure development on the Indian
side India also demands that the troops
be withdrawn to the status who before
the tensions rose
which is exactly what happened when the
dockland standoff
20:17 ended what is behind these
repeated standoffs this isn't the first
time this has happened so what is
causing these well I mean this is
basically because the line between the
two countries the line of actual control
is a contested border there are large
swaths of with which the two countries
see eye to eye on but there are still
many points of conflict whether have
been advances and then have been
standoff similar to what we saw earlier
earlier last month in mail now one of
the main reasons that leads to these
standoffs is infrastructure development
on both sides we talked about how in
Dhokla in 2017 India try to stop
infrastructure development by China
there is also speculation that this
year's standoff over the last few weeks
has been because China has objected to
infrastructure development by India I'm
not the common allegation from both
sides is the troops have advanced into
the other territory this is what India
has said about Chinese troops this year
as well but again there is also concerns
and analyst surveys that because of
China's conventional military
superiority and because India would not
want to escalate this conflict further
this might be a way for China to take up
small sorts of land and call and create
land grabs so this is something that
India will definitely be watching for
and bringing up in discussions with
China mr Joyce wall in Delhi there thank
you